Oh Black Friday is tomorrow  unfortunately though we've seen the  inflation just kind of causing prices to  Surge and and that means Shoppers are  looking for deals which ultimately means  they might be falling for more scams out  there online scam prevention company  social catfish has some tips though so  you don't become a victim yourself first  don't fall for the fake deals you see on  gaming consoles check websites for bad  spelling that's a sign second buy gift  cards directly from the stores or a  store's websites steer clear of gift  sites like giftcards.com third  be careful buying a pet online a lot of  those fake sellers will just take your  money then you never get your animal and  finally don't fall for fake shipping  notifications only track packages on  official websites your FedEx's UPS USPS  or on the Amazon app that's the only way  you should do it